[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right here we are
oh
we're back here at our bushcraft
survival shelter we got a little problem
one of our trees fell over see how we
have this tree here supporting our cross
members
this one fell over
well looks like we better get started we
got a lot of work to do
they could be getting cold all right
i'll get a fire going
oh
so
when it's snowing like this you got to
be really careful where you put your
tools down they'll disappear and get
buried like that
stuff
gets lost really easy
when it's snowing like this and you
won't find it till springtime got to
make sure you always put it somewhere
not in the snow
hey
hey jake you like that
yeah
[Music]
so
so
so
so
[Music]
uh
so
did you see your all right
oh okay
get down here
all right
well guys i've been rushing like a
madman to get to this point but we got a
shelter up so we can keep the snow off
all of our gear which is great because
it was getting this wet
and i got the caught up it got a little
bit higher this time so i got room to
put the sled down on here with their
gear and i got a little bed area that
i'm gonna make for jacob but we need to
block the wind and i need to put
something over here and over here and
maybe over here
to make this a little bit more windproof
[Music]
a lot of wood cut
but it's all wet
covered in ice
we gotta prop it all up by the fire
they're so wet
so
hey jake how you doing
you warm
oh you're super warm
there you go you like that is that is
that less smoky jacob
yeah
you feel you feeling warm down there
good
well it's getting late i think the sun's
gonna set here in a little bit so i
think i better get some dinner made i
got a little boy who's pretty hungry
open the boat
oh
okay
sit down on my lap
oh look at that meatball
i want them
it's spaghetti and meatballs with
a hammock
oh yes you had a good time
good stuff
you know it seems like every time we go
winter camping i burn up at least one
item i'm up to two so far this trip i
stick my water bottle by the fire to
keep it from freezing and um apparently
i stick it too close
by the fire yeah it's got a goiter now
and check out jacob's boot it was
sitting here by the fire and not only
did it melt the tread but it caught on
fire it was
yeah it was bad
oh
[Applause]
i can tell it's gonna be an expensive
trip
got some very frozen marshmallows here
warm cup of hot chocolate with a
marshmallow it tastes pretty good on a
night like tonight
oh you okay
well you know we've actually done better
with time management on this trip than
we have on others you know we've got
dinner done at a reasonable time and
we've got a bit of time to kill do you
want to watch a movie together
we're kicking it with old school
transformers
we had a great time watching shows
together but jake is out like a light
which is good it's as fast as bedtime
but i got a few hours before i'm gonna
go to bed uh so i'm just gonna slowly
get things ready
and i'm going to show you a little bit
about the shelter here
all right here's a real popular trick
you take some boiling water and you put
it in one of these hard plastic
thermoses and then you stick it in your
sleeping bag and it warms your sleeping
bag up really nicely the one thing i
really don't like about this trick
though is if that bottle leaks
oh man you are in deep trouble so you
really really want to make sure that the
lid's on properly and you've got zero
leakage
it'll be nice and toasty when you're
ready to get inside
all right let's go and measure how
efficient our shelter is today
so it looks like we're about 16 degrees
out here in the shelter so really
similar attempt to what we had last time
so it's supposed to get down to six
degrees tonight
you can see we've got about 38 degrees
fahrenheit here in the shelter
definitely cooler than my last shelter
but better than being outside all right
down here on jacob's bed we've got about
24 degrees fahrenheit here so
significantly colder here on the bottom
luckily he's got caribou hides hand
warmers and a negative 25 bag
yep well despite all the improvements i
made to this shelter i don't think it's
a better shelter it's colder noticeably
colder in here and that's because it's
more spacious i accidentally set the
tripod up about a foot and a half
further back than where it was last time
and so i've got a lot more volume in
here and the fire just doesn't do as
good of a job heating it up but the good
part is that the the bed's higher so
that jacob's got room to sleep out of
the snow and that's a huge deal but also
it means the bed's higher so you can't
sit on the bed and use it like a bench
in front of the fire when you're not
sleeping which is also another downside
so that's why we're kneeling on the
ground over here which is hard on my own
back these are the little details i'm
constantly working on when i build these
shelters there's so many little finicky
details that you need to watch out for
all right gonna hang my socks up to dry
before i go to bed warm dry socks that
feels good
good morning it's 7 00 am and i'm deep
inside my sleeping bag
i need to get out and build a fire
all right well i guess it's time to get
some breakfast going but a lot of my
ingredients are frozen so we got to thaw
that out we just put this frozen block
of cream
here in this
hot water bath sit it by the fire
it'll be thawed out in about five
minutes
all right
nice and liquid
foreign
so
hey bud
dad would you like some bacon
no you want some oatmeal
oh my gosh
okay
you want me to set it right there yes i
didn't wait too
well it was definitely a little nippy
last night but uh we did okay shelter
definitely got the job done
now we got some food in our stomachs and
i think we're gonna go and get
everything slowly packed up
but jake really really wants to go
hunting and shoot the 22 rifle a little
bit
so
well she's been a good shelter for us
just a little bit big but next couple
snowfalls we'll fill in those gaps in
the wall
and uh
it'll be a lot more airtight next time
hey jake you want to shoot the 22
you want to shoot the gun no
okay see that little stuff
oh there's more blood you see
see i put the holes right there
all right when we walk back to the car
we're gonna look for some snowshoe hair
they're a rabbit that changes color they
turn white in the wintertime and they
have little black noses little black
eyes and the rest of them is all white
so they're really camouflaged i'm gonna
do a hunt in one
swats all right here we go
we just gotta go really slow through the
woods
and take our time
the old rule of thumb
is if you're walking fast enough to stay
warm you're going too fast you got to go
real slow
and look under every tree
i actually seen some tracks some are
covered up with a little bit of snow
and others are looking fresh you see
right there there's a fresh track right
there that's the hind feet those are the
front feet he's heading this way
and you can see
there's fresh tracks on top of old
tracks
so this is a spot he goes quite
frequently might not be a bad place to
put a snare you want to go back to the
car
all right guys i think it's time to call
it this is a very short-lived rabbit
hunting trip but sometimes those are the
funnest ones
well guys i hope you enjoyed watching
this video as much as we enjoyed filming
if you want to see more camping and
adventure videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel check out our camping
and adventure playlist with over 60
videos of our camping adventures around
the world
i'll put a link in the video description
below and don't forget to
subscribe
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
you have fun bud
good